well I think writing is due it's not the
actual sentences though it's not the
language I think for most people I think
you can write a sentence as well as you
can write it I mean it sounds like a
truism but but in fact if you work on it
long enough write it enough times you
can write it as well as you can write it
you may not write it as well as as John
Updike could write it but you can write
it as well as you can write it the hard
part of most writing i think is the
structure of wanting to know of trying
to figure out what goes first and what
goes second and how that leads into
something that that doesn't jump around
and or at least the hard part of the
sort of writing i usually do i think the
hard part of of say trying to write a
column or a piece of humor is just
staring at the page and realizing might
now be able to write anything I mean
that's not true and reporting pieces
where you have a sort of a corpus to
work
you